if you stop exploring and it kind of
doesn't matter what it is
your backyard the bottom of the ocean
species that live in the canopy of
rainforests that are undiscovered some
insect or somebody some amazing fern
that doesn't epiphyte that doesn't ever
need to have contact with the ground if
you stop looking for those let alone on
Mars and other worlds and other stars if
you stop exploring what does that say
about you said okay I'll stay home don't
worry about me I'll be fine I tell you
if you take that attitude you are not
gonna move forward as a species and
especially talking about economic times
your country's economy will fall behind
space exploration stimulates the economy
space exploration is what I like to call
trickle up investment when you get a
bunch of well-educated people running
around in society it raises the level of
intellectual achievement for everybody
so for me the search for
extraterrestrial life is part of space
exploration and therefore something you
just do
Copernicus goes the sun's is the center
not the earth everybody is like what did
ya the earth goes around the Sun oh now
everything adds up now the ancient
observations now it's all lines up
Galileo says hey you know we're not the
only planet with a moon oh we're gonna
have to put you in prison I'm sorry
we're gonna have to keep you in prison
if you're gonna insist no but look it's
not me
so if we found evidence of life
elsewhere it would humble us in the same
way so there are many people that are
troubled by this uncertainty by this
inability to know and they want to have
all the answers and have it all settled
but that's not the nature of nature and
furthermore it's especially not the
nature of science science is this
process where we keep making discoveries
in a disciplined fashion
and in general the more discoveries you
make the more you realize you don't know
what's going on the more you realize you
don't know not knowing the next physics
whatever is causing the Stars to
accelerate away from each other not
knowing really where gravity comes from
not knowing the future these are all
very troubling to some people but to us
in science it is it's exciting it's
always exciting you're always going to
find something especially in space